welcome back everyone this is part three
in our series on contextual
representations we have a bunch of
famous transformer-based architectures
that we're going to talk about a bit
later but before doing that I thought it
would be good to pause and just reflect
a little bit on this important notion of
positional encoding this is an idea that
I feel the field took for granted for
too long I certainly took it for granted
for too long and I think we now see that
this is a crucial factor in shaping the
performance of Transformer based models
let's start by reflecting on the role of
positional encoding in the context of
the Transformer I think the central
observation is that the Transformer
itself has only a very limited capacity
to keep track of word order the
attention mechanisms are themselves not
directional it's just a bunch of dot
products and there are no other
interactions between the columns and so
we are in grave danger of losing track
of the fact that the input sequence ABC
is different from the input sequence CBA
positional encodings will ensure that we
retain a difference between those two
sequences no matter what we do with the
representations that come from the model
kind of secondarily there's another
purpose that positional encodings play
which is kind of hierarchical they've
been used to keep track of things like
premise hypothesis in natural language
inference that was an important feature
of the Bert model that we'll talk about
a bit later in the series
I think there are a lot of perspectives
that you could take on positional
encoding to keep things simple I thought
I would Center our discussion around two
crucial questions the first is does the
set of positions need to be decided
ahead of time
and the second is does the positional
encoding scheme hinder generalization to
new positions
I think those are good questions to
guide us one other rule that I wanted to
introduce is the following
modern Transformer architectures might
impose a max length on sequences for
many reasons related to how they were
designed and optimized I would like to
kind of set all of that aside and just
ask whether the positional encoding
scheme itself is imposing anything about
length generalization separately from
all that other stuff that might be
happening
so let's start with absolute positional
encoding this is the kind of scheme that
we have talked about so far on this
scheme we have word representations and
we also have positional representations
that we have learned corresponding to
some fixed number of dimensions and to
get our con our position sensitive word
representation we simply add together
the word Vector with the position vector
how is this scheme doing for our two
crucial questions well not so well first
obviously the set of positions needs to
be decided ahead of time when we set up
our model we will have some embedding
space Maybe up to 512.
and if we picked 512 when we hit
position 513 we will not have a
positional representation for that
position
clear that this kind of scheme can
hinder generalization to new positions
even for familiar phenomena just
consider the fact that the rock as a
phrase if it occurs early in the
sequence is simply a different
representation than the rock if it
appears later in the sequence
there will be some shared features
across these two as a result of the fact
that we have two word vectors involved
in both places but we add in those
positional representations as equal
Partners in this representation and I
think the result is very heavy-handed
when it comes to learning
representations that are heavily
position dependent and that could make
it hard for the model to see but in some
sense the rock is the same phrase
whether it's at the start of the
sequence or the middle or the end
scheme we could consider actually goes
all the way back to the Transformers
paper I've called this frequency-based
positional encoding there are lots of
ways we could set this up but the
essential idea here is that we'll define
a mathematical function that given a
position will give us back a vector that
encodes information about that position
kind of semantically in its structure in
the Transformer paper they picked a
scheme that's based in frequency
oscillation so essentially based in sine
and cosine frequencies for these vectors
where higher positions oscillate more
frequently and that information is
encoded in the position Vector that we
create I think there are lots of other
schemes that we could use the essential
feature of this is this argument pause
here if you give this function num
position one it gives you a vector if
you give it 513 it gives you a vector if
you give it a million it gives you a
vector and all of those vectors
manifestly do encode information about
the relative position of that input
so we have definitely overcome the first
limitation the set of positions does not
need to be decided ahead of time in this
scheme because we can fire off a new
Vector for any position that you give us
but I think our second question remains
pressing just as before this scheme can
hinder generalization to new positions
even for familiar phenomena in virtue of
the fact that we are taking those word
representations and adding in these
positional ones for different positions
as equal Partners as I said and I think
that makes it hard for models to see
that the same phrase could appear in
multiple places
the third scheme is the most promising
of the three that we're going to discuss
this is relative positional encoding
we're going to take a few steps to build
up an understanding of how this scheme
works let's start with a reminder this
is a picture of the attention layer of
the Transformer we have our three
position sensitive inputs here a input B
input and C input and remember it's
crucial that they be position sensitive
because of how much symmetry there is in
these dot product attention mechanisms
here's a reminder about how that
calculation works with respect to
position C over here
for positional encoding we really just
add in some new parameters so what I've
depicted at the bottom of the slide here
is the same calculation that's at the
top except now in two crucial places I
have added in some new vectors that
we're going to learn representations for
down in blue here we have key
representations which get it added into
this dot product and we up here in the
final step we have value representations
which get added in to this multiplied
attention mechanism plus the thing we're
attending to
so those are the crew two new crucial
parameters that we're adding in here and
the essential idea is that having done
this with all the position sensitivity
that's going to be encoded in these
vectors we don't need these green
representations here anymore to have
positional information in them because
that positional information is now being
introduced in the attention layer
because we're going to have potentially
new vectors for every combination of
position as indicated by these
subscripts
but that's only part of the story I
think the really powerful thing about
this method is the notion of having a
positional encoding window
so to illustrate that I've repeated the
core calculation at the top here as a
reminder and now for my illustration I'm
going to set the window size to 2.
here's the input sequence that we'll use
as an example and above that I'm going
to show you just integers corresponding
to the positions those aren't directly
ingredients into the model but they will
help us keep track of where we are in
the calculations
to start the illustration let's zoom in
on position four
if we follow the letter of the
definitions that I've offered so far for
the key values here we're going to have
a vector A4 4 corresponding to us
attending from position four to position
four
as part of creating this more limited
window based version of the model we're
actually going to map that into a single
Vector w0 for the keys
now we travel to the position one to the
left and in this case we would have a
vector a43 for the keys but what we're
going to do is map that into a single
Vector W minus 1 corresponding to taking
3 minus four
when we travel one more to the left we
get uh position four two but now we're
going to map that to Vector W minus two
again for the keys
and then because we set our window size
to 2 when we get all the way to that
leftmost position that's also just W
minus two again four minus 1 given the
window size takes us just to the maximum
of this window in this case minus two
and then a parallel thing happens when
we travel to the right so we go from
four to five that gives us Vector W1 for
the keys then 4 6 gives us W2 and then
when we get to the third position from
our starting point that again just
flattens out to W2 because of our window
size
so actually represented in blue here we
have just a few vectors the zero one the
minus one and the minus two one
and then the one two vectors as opposed
to all the distinctions that are made
with those Alpha sub 4 3 and 4 2 and so
forth so we're collapsing those down
into a smaller number of vectors
corresponding to the window size
and then to continue the illustration if
we zoom in on position three that would
be Vector a33 for the keys but now that
gets mapped to w0k which is the same
Vector that we have up here in that 4 4
position and a similar collapsing is
going to happen down here so when we
move 1 to the left of that we get minus
one which is the same Vector as we had
up here just to the right
and then we have the same thing over
here minus 2 corresponding to the same
Vector that we had above
and that would continue and we have a
parallel calculation for the value
parameters that you see in purple up
here the same Notions of relative
position and window size so we actually
learn a relatively small number of
position vectors and what we're doing is
essentially giving a small window
relative notion of position that's going
to kind of slide around and give us a
lot of ability to generalize to new
positions based on combinations that
we've seen before possibly in other
parts of these inputs
a final thing I'll say is that this is
actually embedded in that full theory of
attention that might have a lot of learn
parameters and might even be
multi-headed so what I've depicted here
is just the full calculation just to
really give you all the details but
again the cognitive shortcut is that
it's the previous attention calculation
with these new positional elements added
in and again a reminder in this new mode
we introduce position relativity in the
attention layer not in the embedding
layer
so let's think about our two crucial
questions first we don't need to decide
the set of positions ahead of time we
just need to decide on the window and
then for a potentially extremely long
string we're just sliding it around in
it using a relatively few number of
positional vectors to keep track of
relative position
and I think we have also largely
overcome the concern that positional
embeddings might hinder generalization
to new positions after all
if you consider a phrase like the rock
the core position vectors that are
involved there are 0 1 and -1 no matter
where this appears in the string now
depending on where it appears there will
be other positional things that are
happening and other information will be
brought in as part of the calculation
but we do have this sense of constancy
that will allow the model to see that
the rock is the same essentially
wherever it appears in the string
so my hypothesis is that because we have
overcome these two crucial limitations
relative positional encoding is a very
good bet for how to do positional
encoding in general in the Transformer
and I believe that that is now well
supported by results across the field
for the Transformer